it the way that the human race has
evolved it is virtually guaranteed that
sex is going to die in emotionally
committed relationships and you can
either bail out or tell yourself you
pick the wrong person and if you just
found the right person they'd love all
your flaws and no matter what you did
they just think that you're the bee's
knees and that's the picture most of us
have we're supposed to have in childhood
but that's not marriage marriage people
get fed up with you leaving your socks
on the floor and having all your little
habits and they get tired of telling you
that you're wonderful and propping you
up and they want you to stand on your
own two feet and be a whole man or be a
whole woman and we usually get angry
about that kind of stuff it doesn't fit
our picture you know we sort of the
picture of while we're single I have to
take care of myself once I get married
you ought to take me anyway I am that's
known as loving me and one of the things
sex in marriage and intimacy will teach
you is love is not accepting you any old
way you are when people get married you
get married for better and worse in
sickness and in health but that's not an
excuse this gross the screw off get
sloppy get fat and not take care of
yourself and not be an interesting
person and so sex invariably dies and if
we move on to your next question that's
really the answer to why sex dies all
around the world where rape is not
allowed in women are allowed control of
their own body all around the world from
time immemorial it is the low desire
partner that always control sex now you
might think God's passive-aggressive or
mother nature has a sensitive maybe what
she should have done is made the person
who wants sex the person who's in charge
and the high design your purpose let's
have sex and the low desire partner says
aye aye sir just whatever you say that's
what goes
and it doesn't work that way so what
happens is most of us are going to
destroy the love I want to be with you
but don't tell me what to do and because
the low desire partner controls sex when
the high desire partner says let's have
sex in them low desire partner says well
I'm not so sure in the high desire
partner says well then you don't love me
enough that's the end of sex when it
gets to be proved that you love me do it
my way and the high desire partner says
well why do we always have to do it your
way and the Lord desire partner says
well why don't we always have to do it
your way you are now in the middle of
what happens to all of us that none of
us ever anticipate you are in the middle
of the Wars of self-development and
that's what marriage is about marriage
is about growing up and getting to the
point that you can love somebody on
life's terms and in the middle of that
sex dies and couples go through very
often months or years of not having sex
which nobody was eighteen-years-old ever
believes you know say you get married
you can have sex all the time you're
even living with them they're very
convenient and that's not the way that
it works so what we're really describing
is what made the human brain evolve
where the low desire partner controls
sex the high desire partner doesn't like
that and the high desire partner has to
learn to control themselves because when
the high desire partner says you know
what you're just as controlling is your
mother
that's that basically does not usually
inspire high desire or lubrication in
your partner so you have to learn to
control yourself this also teaches you
to be considerate of your partner and
not act like they belong to you in
getting over the idea that your partner
doesn't belong to you is a tough one
it's a it sounds great when you first
get married we belong to each other
well that's as good as
as long as you're cutting the cake two
years in when your partner acts like
your genitalia belongs to them believe
me it does not inspire passion and when
you go through the way that marriage
really works
which beats out of you the idea that
your partner either belongs to you we're
always supposed to put your needs first
then you become the solid enough person
you were in your own self-respect you
were in each other's self-respect
that's what ignites passion self-respect
is one of the best aphrodisiacs there is
but that's not what you get when you're
first in the the mad passionately in
love with each other stage